c'est certainement son déplacement sur
le front le plus risqué
à baroute vous le dire Zelenski remède
des médailles aux militaires Ukrainiens
sous un tonnerre d'applaudissements
sa déclaration et ponctuée de bruit
d'explosion ici dans le donbasse
vous défendez l'Ukraine
parce qu'après le donbasse il peut faire
la même chose dans d'autres villes
ukrainiennes car ils veulent effacer
tout ce qui est lié à l'Ukraine
le président ukrainien s'est déjà rendu
à plusieurs reprises sur le terrain
auprès des soldats comme un Herson
innovembre ou à sloviance au début du
mois mais voler de venir Hélène qui
n'avait jamais été aussi près des
combats les forces russes tentent de
s'emparer de barmut depuis cet été et
elle se trouve au porte de la ville
ravagée
cette visite apparaît comme une sorte de
défi lancé ave Vladimir Poutine lui ne
sait jamais rendu sur le front et au
même moment il remettait au Kremlin des
décorations à des personnalités russes
et à des dirigeants séparatistes de
l'est de l'Ukraine
le titre de Héros de la Russie est
décerné aux militaires qui ont fait
preuve d'une bravoure particulière au
cours des combats
ce mardi il fait aussi adressé au
service de sécurité russe
oui c'est difficile pour vous maintenant
la situation dans les républiques
populaires de doniace et de louganx dans
les régions de Carson et de zaporigia
est extrêmement difficile quatre régions
que Moscou revendique sans pour autant
les avoir entièrement conquises dis-moi
après le début de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine Vladimir Poutine forme il est
ses aveux de faiblesse les plus claires